Neutrinos sie wohl mysteriösesten
teilchen in unserem universum
sie kommen am häufigsten vor aber wir wissen kaum etwas über sie das kriegen
experiment in karlsruhe will jetzt sind das geheimnis der neutrinos kommen mit der
genauesten waage der welt und dem reinsten vakuum auf der erde so wird das experiment gerne bezeichnet sollen die neutrinos
gewogen werden und vielleicht erfahren wir dabei auch warum es keinen nichts gibt und wieso ist
materie und kaum anti materie im all gibt ihr habt euch das thema whatsapp gewünscht und vielen dank dafür
hat sie bekommen also bei klick zum science and fiction
Heute übrigens vom cern in genf
elektrisch neutral leicht und das häufigste
elementarteilchen überhaupt dass galaxien formt und hinter der bewegung im universum steckt doch wie schwer sind sie
rund 200 forscherinnen und forscher sind beteiligt und dem rätsel auf der spur erstens was will man mit dem
experiment erreichen neutrinos wurden lange zeit auch als
geister teilchen bezeichnet denn sie interagieren nicht mit gewöhnlicher materie oder kaum
sie rasen statt dessen einfach durch sie hindurch durch menschen hände
bäume oder auch sterne und planeten lange ging man also davon aus dass sie keine masse besitzen
doch mittlerweile weiß man dass sie wohl einfach sehr sehr leicht sind eventuell
sind sie sogar zu leicht um sie derzeit überhaupt messen zu können erst vor drei jahren
entdeckte aber macdonald bei direkten messungen der neutrino oszillationen dass sie überhaupt eine masse haben
dafür bekam er einen nobelpreis seitdem sind forschungsteams den neutrino massen dicht auf der spur
wenn es überhaupt gelingt diese zu bestimmen dann mit katrin am karlsruher institut für technologie
kit
denn die messe empfindlichkeit von katrin ist 100 mal empfindlicher als die
bisherige anlagen langfristig wollen forschungsteams durch das verständnis dieser
elementarteilchen aber vor allem die grundfragen des universums verstehen warum gibt es etwas und warum gibt es nicht
einfach nichts konkret also warum es beim urknall ein ungleichgewicht zwischen materie und antimaterie entstanden
zweitens wie genau funktioniert das katrin experiment zurück zum experiment selbst tatsächlich werden gar nicht die neutrinos
gemessen wie auch wenn sie doch wie geistreichen durch alles hindurch gelangen gemessen werden ihre begleiter
elektronen nämlich die entstehen beim zerfall der atome des wasserstoff isotops tritium zu helium
der ganze prozess wird beta zerfall genannt und tritium steckt auch im namen von katrin dass es nämlich die abkürzung für
karlsruhe tritium neutrino
experiment konkret ist das experiment den nackten neutrinos auf der spur also den neutrinos die bei dem beta zerfall
von der freigesetzte energie
abbekommen haben denn da man weiß wie hoch die ursprünglich
freigesetzte energie war kann man von der bewegungsenergie des elektrons eine absolute mesz bestimmung masse bestimmung der
neutrinos vornehmen die einheit dafür mehr mgv also milli
elektronenvolt kurios wenn man bedenkt dass die masse anderer teilchen in einheiten angegeben werden die viele milliarden mal größer sind und so
funktioniert der 70 meter lange
versuchsaufbau konkret tritium ein radioaktives wasserstoffatom tritt in ein vakuum ohr bei seinem zerfall
wandelt sich ein neutron in ein elektron ein proton und ein neutrino wie gesagt
wird dann die bewegungsenergie des elektrons gemessen dafür müssen andere elektronen herausgefiltert werden
dieses geschieht durch ein magnetfeld dass die teilchen durch eine unglaubliche
23 meter lange
vakuumkammer führt und je ist es wirklich ein irrsinniges vakuum
ja und nur die stärksten und schnellsten die zusammen mit dem nackten neutrino entstanden sind die schaffen es bis auf die andere seite
zum detektor am ende des versuchs drittens mit welchen ergebnissen
rechnet man der größte erfolg für die forscherinnen und forscher wäre es mit hilfe von katrin die genaue masse der
neutrinos zu bestimmen dafür müsste sie mehr als 200 msv betragen denn so viel gibt katrin her
bisher liegt die obergrenze bei etwa 2 elektronenvolt und so viel steht fest so viel wiegen neutrinos also noch mal nicht ein
kleiner trostpreis wäre es aber auch mit katrin diese grenze zu verschieben also die angabe einer neuen
obergrenze zu machen die größte sensation aber wäre es wenn katrin frühere modelle komplett wieder legen würde diese hatten aus
beobachtung der alh
hintergrundstrahlung berechnet dass die masse der neutrinos nicht über einem elektronenvolt liegen können andere ergebnisse
würden also die säulen des standardmodells der kosmologie von grund auf
erschüttert viertens wie lange hat katrin zeit 60 millionen euro und 17 jahre arbeit stecken in katrin und forschungsteams setzen große hoffnungen in die anlage
falls bis zum jahr 2023 noch immer keine absolute massen bestimmung möglich sein sollte ist ein
update von katrin geplant dann würden messungen bis
100 msv
möglich werden doch mehr geht definitiv nicht dazu schreibt das wissenschaftsmagazin
science katrin könnte die letzte hoffnung der physiker sein die neutrino masse zu messen zumindest ohne eine
revolutionäre neue
technik wenn ihr keine videos dazu zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte abo boxer auf
youtube und verpasst kein video mehr denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks zum social media abonnieren tag gibt es das neue
social media welt dafür hier klicken aber natürlich nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken neues teilchen entdeckt bis dann
bleibt